what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to top 5 Tuesday a weekly
series where we count down the top 5
characters teams and concepts from
across the comic book industry and this
week we're counting down the top 5
reasons why the Fantastic Four reboot
absolutely sucked number 5 it exists
truthfully we could stop the list right
now in what universe would anyone
believe that this movie needed to be
made as not as all the other two movies
were amazing and this one just missed
the mark the first Fantastic Four film
has a rating of 27 percent on Rotten
Tomatoes and the second movie has a
rating of 37 percent which I guess is
good if you consider going from crappy
to less crappy and improvement taking
those two scores and averaging them with
the 9 percent rating that this film has
and you come out with a stellar 24
percent rating to put this into
perspective for every four people who
have viewed these films one person liked
them and that person should receive a
savage beating with tangerines and a
burlap sack until they change their mind
I mean I get this one was made in a mad
dash to keep the rights but I got to ask
all the rights really worth keeping if
the movies are based on a comic series
it doesn't even matter anymore moreover
this Fox even aware that Marvel canceled
the Fantastic Four comics number four
nothing makes any sense I imagine that
if like tomorrow I woke up in a world
designed by Stephen King with this
inhabitants modeled after the cast of HR
Pufnstuf they would still make more
sense in this movie you would think that
something was off when the comic book
guy from The Simpsons interview the cast
of the film and none of them could
answer the question of what it was about
or what was going on oh my question
would be after watching Josie
the first two you know the only two that
I've ever seen just gallon everything
why
redo why do you another one I mean what
is it just a reboot is what Hollywood is
into is renewing it again was that not
the right fantastic order system follow
more of a comic-book line than the other
one did or why the reason for sometimes
to do is just kind of recycle properties
you think I mean how many beds every
well that's the thing I keep saying why
did that fit when Reed conducts his
experiment for the first time he takes
down power to the whole of New York City
in addition to all of the upper
northeast something that apparently goes
unnoticed by anyone in a position of
authority anywhere and Susan storms hair
changes and I don't mean that it changes
because she styled it differently I mean
that in a single scene that she'll have
blonde hair light blonde hair and in the
next moment she'll have dark blonde hair
when they gain their powers it's because
they were each making physical contact
for something that changed the molecular
structure Johnny Storm was on fire when
he teleported Ben Grimm was covered in
rocks when he teleported and Reed
Richards was somehow involved in rubber
although that was never really explained
here's a question if interaction with
objects forced a merger with their
molecules then why didn't they just
merge with their suits the first time
they teleported number three the
characters are dumb and marvel comics
whether it's the ultimate universe the
mainstream universe or even the universe
for characters age in real time
the Fantastic Four are at least mildly
interesting in this movie there isn't
one redeeming factor about anyone safer
Johnny Storm if the movie ended with
everyone dying in a fiery crash I
probably wouldn't care what makes it so
sad is that if there's any character we
should be able to feel bad for more than
any other it's Ben Grimm this guy goes
from being a stud to a giant rock
monster in the blink of an eye and the
comics his desire to return to his human
form is what makes him relatable because
we all have aspects of ourselves that we
wish we could change but we can't while
he spends most of his time moping around
more often than not he's the voice of
reason and an otherwise chaotic family
Ben Grimm in this movie is just a cranky
dude who looks like clumpy poop and is
mad at Reed for a while and then
inexplicably he's not
there's nothing to identify with here
because we don't know how he feels in a
personal level Reed Richards is
apparently searching for a cure but
miles teller is so removed from caring
about his character that I'm not even
sure he was aware a movie was being made
and Cape Mary's character is introduced
coming off looking like a weird girl
from The Breakfast Club
a Franklin storm is the stereotypical I
have some hidden wisdom father figure
who is head of a school movie has no
control over and Tim Blake Nelson is the
nameless faceless bad guy that could be
played by an extra with no one knowing
the difference number two
the plot is elementary as Steven
Spielberg once said people have
forgotten how to tell a story the
stories don't have a middle and an end
anymore they have a beginning that never
stops beginning now because this quote
comes from a guy who made ET Close
Encounters of the Third Kind and
Jurassic Park we're going to take his
opinion as fact every movie that has
ever existed has three acts to set up
the confrontation and the resolution
this movie has those three things so I
guess it's a success in terms of the
ability to construct script the problem
is that nothing meaningful happens in
those three parts the set up shows Reed
being made fun of by the worst teacher
in history buying a prototype teleporter
and being recruited by Susan and
Franklin storm the Johnny Storm is
introduced as a hothead who wants to
take insane risks and demonstrates this
by working in a lab and Ben Grimm is
Reed's best friend the confrontation
shows them getting powers and being used
by the federal government the resolution
is that dr. doom is defeated and the
government and the Fantastic Four become
besties at the end Wow
what a roller coaster ride of non-stop
action this story is elementary at best
and at worst it's so unoriginal it could
be a sci-fi Channel movie number one
Doctor Doom so with the exception of
number two you may have noticed that
Victor Von Doom was largely absent from
this list well that's because he gets
the number one spot all to himself
according to Fox Victor Von Doom is a
guy who has the hots for Susan storm and
her changing hair colors but is upset
because she doesn't want him
if this was supposed to make doom
relatable - congratulations Fox you
failed the Victor Von Doom from the
comics has remained one of Marvel's
premier villains and a fan favorite for
several reasons he's highly intelligent
he's honorable he never backs down from
a foe and he addresses himself in the
third person Victor Von Doom in this
film has no backstory regarding his life
before the Baxter building there's no
explanation of how he survived on planet
zero after he was presumed dead except
to say that the weird Nickelodeon slime
somehow kept him alive and his powers
are never explained but involves
something making people's heads explode
and apparently something to do with
telekinesis by the end of this film
everything boils down to a team no one
cares about fighting a villain no one
knows anything about in a battle that
may somehow destroy the earth here comes
the Cluetrain Fox the last stop is you
if you're going to make a film involving
a team give us a reason to like them
make the relatable or at least
entertaining give us a villain that we
can rally behind or rally against there
should be something that makes him or
her interesting a driving force maybe
that makes them a victim of circumstance
but in some capacity ensures that we can
relate to them on a more human level
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end I hope you
guys enjoyed it and I will catch you
guys later peace